you were um 200 pounds at 10 years old
right
yeah by 2 000 that was 536 pounds
so i don't see why anything you say
about my feelings about myself
should be able to alter my feelings
about myself but we've gotten into this
space where
the group can dictate how people
view themselves and not only that the
group
must dictate how people view themselves
what's your t-shirt say uh it says i
killed my clone today what's that a
reference to
um there's a there is a
uh martial arts guy i i did a television
show
called chance with a fellow countryman
of yours hugh laurie
and i played this character where i was
like um
basically my first official badass
character
and the the character was based on a
real guy
who is actually a military and martial
arts instructor
he teaches like the elite military dudes
how to fight with knives like that's his
job
and so in playing in in meeting him and
spending time with him i
trained with him a bunch and he had this
whole philosophy about kill your clone
so
every day you meet
the clone of yourself from 24 hours in
the past
and you have to fight to the death and
if you've
improved yourself by 1 thousandth of a
percent that day
you will kill your clone so the point is
to
kill your clone every day so this shirt
is uh saying that today i i did that i
killed my clone
that's so sick man i'm gathered i'm
gasped for today's episode dude i've
just finished training
i nearly did this podcast without shorts
on i keep on nearly forgetting to put
shorts on but i put shorts on
we're here i've got shorts on um
is what's that guy's name what's the tom
kyr
tom kyr is the real life guy that i pl
he's
the character that i played was based on
tom kyr um
if you ever saw a movie called the
hunted with tommy lee jones and benicio
del toro
it's about special forces guys who are
good with knives
he like created all of that knife work
he's a
he's a true badass dude so is it like
krav maga
type stuff or even more i think it's
even uh a
step in in the more hardcore from
more hardcore than israeli military
yeah serious serious [ __ ]
so do you think that's the pivot now for
your
acting direction the sort of big
badass kind of gruff it's always in the
action film it's the dude that's got
two 50 cal machine guns in each hand
you know the belts of of ammunition do
you reckon that's kind of the pivot
direction
this is this is all the pivot i want to
happen who knows if it actually happens
but yes i'm
in give me 250 cows and belt fed machine
guns and all that and i'm
[ __ ] in are we allowed to say [ __ ]
you can say [ __ ] as much as you want
my friend yeah that would be because i
mean you're not going to do
sweet young uncle very well anymore i
don't think you can do that
yeah i hope not i don't want to do it
i've done it
quite a bit yeah you know like you can't
just play the best friend because you
who's that guy like oh it's just that's
just like uncle bob in the corner it's
like
uncle bob looks like he wants to kill
someone yeah
it's such a weird thing too because with
acting
i feel like i uh i can
play that kind of innocent sweet kind of
dumb
buddy or brother very well and i've done
i've done it a lot
but like as a little kid i never uh
physically matched this but i loved
action movies and
and shoot em ups and stuff you know so
my dream would be for sure to do
something like that
uh i've not gotten to do it but i would
love to bro it's happening
it's happening so hard and i'm going to
be there me and michael mallis are going
to be there
with a huge huge tub of popcorn well
michael wanks he's still counting
calories
but um i'll be there with a huge tub of
popcorn mike will be there with a diet
drink
uh it might be re-feed day you never
know and then he'll have bubble gum
flavored ice cream
that guy man do you see that he's doing
what was it he told me he's doing a
creme egg challenge
do you tell you about this i don't know
i don't know about this every week
i get a message on signal from him
that's like dude am i one of your
countrymen yet and he's ordered
every different type of british jam that
he can get do you see his cereal the
thing when he was doing
all that different cereal yes what on
earth
malice i know that you're listening man
like i love you but
i i get worried because somewhat someday
someone's going to send you something in
the post
which is 45 year old uh
like confectionaries or something and
it's gonna kill you and i don't want
that to happen
i don't want it to happen but god damn
he's gonna have
fun he's gonna go out in style man yeah
he's eating a fossilized chili from
the 5 000 years ago or whatever it is
that he's managed to find on ebay
the guys are savage and so look man why
don't you i want to know about sort of
your fitness journey
um starting at when you were at your
heaviest and taking you till now
right my fitness journey has been a bit
of a roller coaster um
i i mean if we go back to like five
years old
at five years old i think if you looked
at me today
i would not look like an overweight
five-year-old i had chubby cheeks
i definitely had a bit of excess fat but
i wasn't
fat i went to visit my grandparents and
they were like holy [ __ ]
this kid's lost this kid parents are
doing nothing for him
we're putting him on a diet and so i
kind of developed this
um
way of eating very early on which was i
i would sneak food
because at five food was restricted and
if i wanted a second helping of food i'd
have to eat it in the kitchen very
quickly before anybody could see
and so then i just kept getting put on
diets
throughout my life but i was very good
at cheating
at diets because i didn't want to be on
a diet it was kind of like this
authoritarian thing of like
you're on this diet now yeah and my mom
bless her heart was always
very excited when the nutritionist or
whoever it was
would say like oh you understand it's
not that he eats too much it's that he's
eating
this food that is poisoning him if he
could just
handle candida he wouldn't be fat
anymore or
i remember as a kid there was a period i
don't even know what the diet was called
but where it was like
white foods are bad as long as he
doesn't eat anything
white and it was literally like white
potatoes
are bad and white cabbage is bad red
cabbage is fine
you know like apples are bad oh no no
not apples green apples are bad
mayonnaise is bad cottage cheese anyway
and then there was
uh subsequently years later a red phase
where it was like
anything red is bad white cabbage is
good red cabbage is bad anyway [ __ ]
chaos right and
so by the time i became kind of
autonomous
and started working as an actor and had
money i was like
the greatest thing you can do is hit a
fast food drive through
at two o'clock in the morning i didn't
really like eating in front of people
and so
at that point my weight skyrocketed
um by uh 2000 that was
536 pounds now i say 536 pounds because
i fairly sure i was heavier than that at
some point but
um i i
had weighed myself once because that you
can't
you don't have a scale that can tell you
that weight at your house
so i went to a place that had a special
scale weighed myself
left and was like well [ __ ] it i mean
that's the number
i what do i do and i gained weight from
there too so i have no idea what i
actually got to do you were um
200 pounds at 10 years old right yeah 10
years old that was 200 pounds and that's
when my parents started putting me on
diets prior to that
my grandparents had put me on diets but
after ten
my parent my my father was like enough
for this
what age were you at the 536
5 36 probably 21.
um and
not long after that i met a girl
the girl never brought up my weight once
she was
hot and i had been with girls that i
didn't really care about
before that that you meet at a nightclub
and
you know i wasn't i never thought about
future with girls and so suddenly i'm
with this girl and and
and i'm starting to think about like
wanting to have a long-term relationship
with her
and uh and i realized that
the things that she enjoyed doing um
i wasn't necessarily cut out to do
she liked hiking and spending days at
the beach and
going on trips to europe and walking
around all day and i was like
no europe you sit at a cafe and you just
eat and then you
you know you have a car hired to take
you somewhere else like you don't walk
around
uh you know i'd never taken public
transportation
and she's like telling me about how
great the train systems in
london and paris are and i'm like uh
yeah i'm not
just not gonna do that so i started to
think about weight loss and that so the
first time
i decided that i needed to lose weight
it was about maintaining this
relationship with the girl
and i i had the most bizarre
situation where i had to ask her for
help
and in asking her for help i was scared
because she had never brought it up and
it was almost like i have a secret
i have to tell you this she might not
know she might not know
that i'm overweight and i need to lose
weight right i'm 500 plus
pounds and i really had this like fear
of like if i tell
her that i'm overweight she'll know how
will she ever be able to look at me the
same way again
i don't want to ruin this um
and i finally broke down and said like i
don't know what to do
this is crazy i gotta let you in on this
secret i'm 500 pounds
i have some excess weight could you help
me take it off
and she was like oh yeah we can do that
no problem here's this diet like let's
just do something extreme
here's this i'll figure it all out you
don't think about anything
and like found this diet which was
um a liquid diet of like protein
shakes and a [ __ ] handfuls of
supplements vitamins and and fiber and
[ __ ] like that in a ton of water no
no solid food which by the time i
got through that i lost 80 pounds in two
months and
that 80 pounds plus the next 20 like so
that hundred pounds
i never gained weight back into that
that was weight that i kept on chopped
off the top the very top of that yeah
boom i never now when you get down into
like
under 400 pounds i've
been back and forth a couple of times um
and that was really a lot of trying to
figure out what diet
i was gonna do like you know i'm a sober
person
my wife is not and uh i'm not like some
kind of like an
abstinent abstinence fiend or anything
like that have you always been sober
no i've been to rehab a couple of times
and so
sobriety is something i need to do
rather than want to do i have no
uh it's not something i necessarily
enjoy
other than the fact that i know it
allows me to have the life i have
um but like when i look at uh
my addictive nature with food
having given up drugs and alcohol
there is something kind of i don't want
to say easy because i don't want to
disrespect
anybody who has trouble with that but
the idea that you just
are either doing something or not doing
something
is that level of responsibility seems
easy to meet you cannot do that with
food
food like it or not if you have
trouble with that there is going to be
some situation where you have to
expose that to food yeah exactly um
so it's been a long hard journey
figuring that out i started
um i lost weight i then
did a job for a number of years called
my name is earl i gained weight back
i after that i started became obsessed
with
cycling i lost a [ __ ] load of weight i
got
actually thin um was not comfortable
with that
decided to lift weights and put muscle
on did that was loving that then
was like i will work better as a fat guy
so continued to go to the gym but
ate everything in sight and got really
big close to 400 pounds again
i bet you were strong at that point
though yeah i was lifting weights
every day but i wasn't lifting weights
in the way i do now i just went to the
gym
and picked up whatever heavy like you
know how heavy can i go on the bench
press oh
i can do 405 like i'm just gonna do 405
then that's what i'll do and i wasn't
even like
really doing i just lift it until i
couldn't lift it anymore and then that's
done with that you know it wasn't the
smartest
like i it took me a long time to like
get
smart about all of this um
i got really big again but also
much more muscular and then uh
i was doing that show i mentioned to you
with hugh laurie called chance
um and i i was really big
very strong and for the second season i
was like what would this be like if i
took a little bit of the fat off but
kept the muscle
so i did that the second season i'm in
better health
better shape and then after that show
ended we did two years of that show
i was like i want to lose weight but
still
be a big guy because i'm comfortable
more comfortable being
kind of big and for for a year i did
keto trying to maintain muscle mass and
i would notice
through i would get dexa scans and
notice that like 30 to 40 percent of the
weight i was losing was lean tissue
and i was getting smaller but my muscle
wasn't staying as big i was losing
strength which was a bummer so i just
got really
scientific about it increased my protein
which in doing that you can't it kind of
defeats keto
is that right does enough protein knock
you out of ketosis yeah
um i i i eat about 280 grams of protein
a day
and the amount of fat that i'd have to
eat
in order to not have any of the
protein go through um glucogenesis in
the liver
would just be astronomically high and
you wouldn't be in a deficit
a caloric deficit and so you you know so
yes
it's very difficult then to use ketosis
to lose weight whilst maintaining
muscle because the requirement that you
have on your fat is proportional to the
protein and if you drop your protein
down so much inevitably your muscles are
going to atrophy
i listen if you
tried to do keto i'm sure there's a
version of
you doing it and not damaging your
muscles
you could probably do that but when
you're looking at losing
a hundred pounds of fat which is
roughly what i wanted to lose that's
just such a
long period of time of weight loss that
it is
gonna be hard to maintain all that
muscle mass so i i get into these things
where people are like
you're dead wrong about keto and i'm
like look i'm not knocking keto
keto i [ __ ] lost a ton of weight and
keto might be
perfectly fine for a person who's fit or
who wants to lose a couple pounds
and maintain all their muscle that might
work but when you're talking about doing
it for
years to lose huge amounts of weight
you're gonna sacrifice
lean tissue you just are um without
enough protein and if you raise your
protein high enough
you're not going to be you've got to
have your fat to then keep you
to not be knocked out ketosis which then
puts you over the deficit okay yeah it's
uh
it's very i haven't it's something i
haven't done i remember messing around
with it when it became cool
like maybe sort of eight years ago and
uh
i have such low fat in my diet all the
time just naturally i don't tend to eat
fatty foods
and it really didn't agree with me i
don't operate tremendously well
uh so but i totally get it as well
michaela peterson i was recently on her
podcast that girl eats beef salt and
water
yeah she's got the the maddest diet on
the planet
and um a lot of the people that follow
her stuff are either on
beef salt and water or some version of
keto is kind of like the overarching
theme of that
and uh i would just uh my i
listen i'm not even against it i'm not
advocating against it i'm just saying
i would be willing to bet she came to it
at a place where it wasn't like
i needed to lose a hundred pounds of fat
and maintain
my level of fitness so i just think it's
like
you know if you're going to be doing
something that puts you in a deficit for
years you've got to look at what you're
focusing on that's all so what did you
what did you settle on
after all of that playing around with
all different diets what what
did you settle on to keep the weight
loss sustainable
low fat high protein moderate carbs
what were your macros or your cows are
around about
i i mean for maintenance i'm like 3 500
to 4 000 calories a day for maintenance
uh my deficit is around 2500
and the first thing i do is go like how
do i get 260 grams of protein 260 to 280
grams of protein today
and then the next thing that i work out
is carbohydrates and it changes
you know almost month to month it's
going gonna be different
a little bit and depending on you know
if it's my day off
i'll lessen my carbs and increase my
fats a little bit
but fat is definitely the
the the guy getting shortchanged
and i will sometimes go solo fat that i
gotta take a handful of
omega threes just to hit my fat markers
yeah i feel like i'm so i have double
cream in coffee on a morning
in a desperate attempt to remember to
get some
fat since if i don't i'll be so far
under so i think yeah
similar to you so i mean that without
getting sort of super technical into it
a if three and a half to four thousand
cows
was maintenance for you and your deficit
was
two thousand five hundred that's a
fairly aggressive
put that's a pound and a half to two
pounds a week
that's what i'm trying to do on a cut
yeah i'm trying to hit like one percent
of my weight
per week [ __ ] man what did you feel
like mentally cognition because you've
got to perform you've got to go out
there you've got to do a thing you know
i can as long as i've not got a podcast
to do i can sit behind the laptop
do the emails send a message read some
books prepare for a guest do whatever i
need to do
like you've got to be a game
biggest blockbusters up against like
hugh laurie
leonardo dicaprio like they're bringing
the [ __ ] fire you know like you can't
be rolling in going
well i'd love to be a 10 out of 10 guys
but actually i'm in this 1000 calorie
deficit so i've only got sort of
seven out of 10 in the in the tank what
were you doing there
i i've done every version of
diet while working and i've even done
like
you know the [ __ ] really stupid diets
it's like everybody eats 600
calories a day for two months and
you know you're gonna be light-headed
every time you stand up you're gonna be
constantly
cold like you're not gonna have any
energy at all
and it's not it's not really worth it
trying to do something like that
at work for me so so now when i go to
work
if i'm doing intense 15 16 hour days i
try to do maintenance
i i do maintenance calories um and i
always take my own food
i don't mess around with the the
catering or craft services at all
because
there's just no telling what's in any of
that stuff and
and if it's a packaged food i try to not
eat a lot of prepackaged food
anyway um that i haven't packaged for
myself
um but yeah it's it's it's rough doing a
an extreme diet
while trying to work it's it's rough
doing a diet
and going to the gym and having kids and
like having
a house that i have to participate in
also you know but
i've found that um
the difference between the diet i'm on
now and the diets
i've done in the past were mainly
because when i when i was doing keto for
years the idea that i had was
that it was just carbohydrates and by
the way
it took a couple years to get to the
idea that it was all carbohydrates
because leading up to that it was
just gluten or white food or red food
yeah and it was this idea that it had
nothing to do with me and my personal
responsibility it was this
evil food that was poisoning me
and shifting my mind around
because in fairness the first three or
four days of eating carbohydrates i
gained nine pounds and was
freaking out like so when you switched
from
keto to counting calories and
macronutrients
added carbs back in you gained
nine pounds in three days which
is i didn't go from
keto to maintenance to a cut i went from
keto to a cut yeah and i gained nine
pounds and all the alarm bells went off
the i just was sitting there dude going
like how long
am i going to do this like am i going to
gain 30 pounds
hoping that i lose weight like it was
crazy
yeah it was a lot it was a lot to
overcome
mentally i shouldn't have been getting
on the scale every day at that point i
should have gone like give me i'll do it
in a week i'll get on the scale and see
what happens again
like this is the benefit of hindsight
you know there is someone listening
right now who's on a long term
multi-month multi-year
cut who's got a lot of weight to lose
and they're thinking
i might try and go to counting calories
and macronutrient profile instead of
doing keto
and they're going to have what happened
to you but not stick it out
yeah yeah so by telling them that you've
you know
that is that is golden information but
you have to earn it in the
the fire that is the crucible of
personal experience right
yeah and and you it's it becomes such a
mind [ __ ]
because depending on what diet book
you've read or what your group of
friends are doing
you become religious about these ideas
about
food and and i've eventu you know
there's a movement in l.a
about lectins which is just maybe a
broader word for nightshades i guess i
you know i remember as a kid hearing
about nightshades being bad and now it's
lectins
[ __ ] take a look at what lectins are in
lectins are in
everything you can't find a food that uh
you know a vegetable
that doesn't have lectins in it and so
i'm going like
what are you guys talking about now
plants are toxic now vegetables are
toxic like this is
crazy but if it's working for you
i say good for you i just don't i i
think
like the trouble i have with it is going
it's this type of food it has nothing to
do with me it has nothing to do with my
habits and behavior
and then when i tried to change it up
three days of weight gain i was going
like well this is
insane this clearly doesn't work
and it's the evil food narrative kind of
comes back in again
yeah i made it through those three days
day four
i lost two pounds so i'm still seven
pounds up
in my cut and uh
and i just was like i gotta try
something different because what i'm
doing
i'm losing 40 lean tissue
every two months when i get my dexa scan
and and i
that's all i just didn't want to do that
you know over the course of a 100 pounds
that's 40 pounds of muscle that i've
lost
um hard-earned harder i mean i mean
listen dude
i went from 200
just about 200 pounds to just about
400 pounds in the gym lifting weights
every day
i put on a shitload of muscle in that in
those
years of lifting weights and eating
everything in sight and i had [ __ ]
giant traps
and my thought was what would it be like
if i just took the muscle off i'll be a
[ __ ] bodybuilder i was so excited
and then i went to keto and like i
i probably gave up 30 pounds of muscle
and i
listen i don't know that i need 30
pounds of muscle from where i am now i
have
uh 230 pounds of lean tissue right now
so 250 pounds
that is like you're getting near to like
bodybuilder size
i mean you're i'm i'm probably
technically bodybuilder size now
once i get to like seven percent body
fat hopefully i'll
look more like a bodybuilder but like
i i do have that thing of like what is
my goal and i want to do the thing that
gets me to my goal
the best i don't want to do a thing
because i have this
preconception that's not necessarily
scientifically sound
that i can't eat gluten or i can't eat
[ __ ] bell peppers or whatever it is
no red foods no orange foods
yeah that's just i think that's it
becomes disingenuous and
so now i can basically eat whatever i
want
um and i will say to go from
keto which became
very easy for me chicken and like
there's a couple
different modes of keto if i'm doing a
[ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] keto i'm
eating
hot dogs without the buns and dipping
them in nacho cheese sauce right which
today i'm going like how the hell did i
do that that's
to me seems poisonous now and if i was
doing a very strict version of keto
it would be chicken thighs and broccoli
covered in olive oil
and i learned eventually that even doing
that
mindlessly i wasn't losing weight so i'd
have to do that in moderation
to really lose weight and the weight i
was losing
was also lean tissue um
so let's take it like high level then so
you can go back to the year
2000 year 536
and you can send a nice
big email drafting out a diet plan
and a training regime what do you send
to yourself
ugly i think the thing my wife found me
who was my girlfriend at the time
uh the liquid diet i think at 5 36
that's perfect i think that because
there's something about my level of
responsibility where
i'm so overwhelmed by food
at that point that the taking it down to
like just be responsible for drinking
this shake three times a day
and eating this handful of fiber or
whatever the hell
the vitamins were um that's it
that's all you have to do don't think
about counting calories don't think
about
you know removing you know omega-6s
and increasing omega-3s like don't think
about that just be responsible for this
and then the the problem i had was
once because you can't really do that
forever that's not a way to live
um once you kind of get through that and
you have this sense of responsibility
over this thing
it's the increasing it this is what i
think about with carnivore folk and i'm
stoked that carnivore works for people
too but when i look at carnivore i go
like
that's a that's an extreme reduction be
responsible for
uh beef salt and water fine but
eventually
i think you want to build out on that
so once you kind of get your feet stable
and you go okay
this isn't hurting me i'm not allergic
to any of these things i'm not having an
adverse
effect let's dip our toes into
vegetables and see
how do we feel when we eat red peppers
and how do we feel when we eat cucumbers
and if you don't have a bad reaction you
know that those are safe foods and
you've now
built into your arsenal of things you
can be responsible for
and you know let's see what happens if
we have a bowl of rice
and then work out an hour later how do
we feel in the gym you know what i mean
i think there's
levels to all these things i i
again i'm a relativist so if it works
for you
then [ __ ] keep going at the end of
the day the only thing that we're
bothered about is the results right
so okay so you're saying there might be
some people listening in fact i'm
absolutely certain that there will be
some people that are like i have a lot
of weight to lose
a potential good starting point would be
this liquid diet what was the
what was the shakes and then where would
you move yourself on to there and when
i i think if you have hundreds of pounds
to lose
that that doing something radical and
extreme like that
isn't such a bad thing first of all you
have so much stored energy
that um you're not
in risk of damaging yourself by going
extremely low calorie right
and also if the way you and i diet today
if you map it out
you go like if you have hundreds of
pounds to lose and you're
losing them very very slowly it's going
to take years and years and years which
i think you do have to confront the fact
that if you've gotten to the place of
hundreds of pounds of excess stored
energy
that you are going to be looking at
something that is a
lifelong alteration of eating habits
that's fine but you want to kind of get
you want to get to goals
as quickly as possible because you want
to build that foundation
that keeps you going i think so doing
something radical
and extreme to start it i have no
problem with and i would
advocate to do that again it's figuring
out
the usefulness and workability of the
next diet
when you do start eating again and the
the problem i kept running into was
this kind of belief system that had to
go along with any diet i was doing so it
was
you know gluten is bad and that's the
trigger or that's the thing that's
causing me to store excess fat so i'm
gonna get rid of that and i i would just
say like
get rid of those ideas and if
you don't like gluten or you have an
adverse effect from gluten that is
objective fine cut gluten out there's a
diet for you
if you don't like fat or you
have trouble digesting fat or you don't
feel good after you eat it
there's a diet for you if you like fat
there's a diet for you
but i think it's more important to be
aware of what you're
actually experiencing versus
you know somebody selling you on lectins
or bad or gluten is bad
or you know gmos are bad or pick your
poison i think there's a school of
thought that
that would point a finger at any kind of
food group
you know from vegans to carnivores
there's that spectrum is full of
avoid the ideology avoid the church of
gluten-free or the church of quito or
the church of carnivore or the church of
whatever it might be
and focus instead on energy balance
what's going in what's going out
am i losing weight am i checking the
scales regularly am i tracking my
food um what's your streak on my fitness
pal what's your longest streak
oh man i that that was actually what i
used
at the beginning because i i was writing
everything down
and there was so much math that i i
would write i would
like to double check my math every day
and sometimes it would be
wrong and i then would be like
completely [ __ ]
um i think i had like three or four
months of check-ins
on my fitness pal at one point which was
great yeah that's serious
i think it does become you know
in a cut certainly i write everything
down every day still
just to make sure but like on
maintenance
i i i'm not even really looking i've
learned
over the past year and a half or so
what that what that looks like what it
feels like
um and and that's the other thing i'd
say to anybody who's
who's thinking about going to calories
and macros
it is an adjustment figuring all this
stuff out
is an adjustment but kind of you kind of
get the hang of it real quick i would
also
suggest anybody who's doing keto to
spend a week writing down
their calories i bet they'd be surprised
at how many calories are in a tablespoon
of olive oil you know and what
what kind of energy that's providing
them with dude that
coffee that i talked about on the
morning which is like a shot
of double cream in a coffee is like
seven percent of my daily calories and
it's the size of
a couple of cubes of sugar but it's it's
mad so i wanted to oh actually before i
do that where are you at now what's
weight and body fat at now have you got
an idea
yeah 260 13 body fat
bro which is good and this is by the way
uh with calipers i'm at nine percent
this is a dexa scan which i always like
to talk about because
um i just think it's a more
hardcore test is there
any residual um
visceral fat is there any sort of
long-term
uh organ organ sort of fat which is
taking more time to get off because i
was learning today about um
brown brown adipose t is it brown
adipose tissue and white adipose tissue
yeah literally reading about that this
morning so that i could i could drop
that knowledge bomb for you right there
yeah that is an amazing knowledge mom
yes my adipose tissue
i don't know that they're telling me
whether it's brown or white in the dexa
scan but i do know that
i am on the high end there but
we're talking not about a huge amount
in in comparison like the adipose tissue
i think i'm at like four pounds
or three three something which to me i
go like that's nothing
but if you think about what it is it's
this uh
very very thin sheet of fat that's
surrounding all your organs so
i don't know if that's just the last
place your body takes fat from that i've
built it up
that's when you know man that's when you
know you lean when you're pancreas lean
when you can see when you can see it's
secreting hormones that's when you know
that you've nailed it
but dude that's that's sick and the next
goal is
sub 10 percent sub 10 is the next goal
this cut will take me to sub 10
to cut i'm doing now [ __ ] man yeah which
i'm stoked about
i'll say and then mass phase
then mass phase which i haven't done i
mean
the the mass phase i did was completely
mindless
and it was a hundred plus pounds
of massing um which is so upsetting
because you know i just didn't do it
right at all
the thing about anyone that does a bulk
and this is even the hardest of hard
gain
teenagers at 17 years old taking mutant
mass
like you have to lose that at some point
yeah
yeah but i wasn't even thinking in those
terms i was just thinking
i i want to put on weight because for
work
i think work will like me more bigger
but i like
lifting weights i've like exercising so
i'm just gonna do both i wasn't
thinking in those terms at all like the
terms i'm thinking in now
are can i put on a pound and a half of
muscle
yeah and then lose the 10 pounds of fat
that come with that
like though you know i'm thinking about
it scientifically you're gonna
you are going to absolutely love
a well adjusted mass phase
with some good output your training is
going to feel better
libido is going to be better
everything's going to improve and i've
been telling
malice this over and over again man like
it was me that told him on this podcast
ask your coach about a refeed day
because i feel like you might be pushing
the deficit a little bit hard
you're struggling with your training
output and the red pill that
he's going to get fed and i feel that
you're kind of on the
on the way to eating as well is that
when you start to do that when you start
to build those calories back
up it becomes like you you stay
the same condition and it starts to fill
out and you're like this is
sick my lifts are going up i feel great
i'm sleeping well i'm
full all the time like it's just it it
is awesome man so i'm super i'm stoked
to see what happens when you start to do
that i can't wait i will say
just on maintenance because i've been
doing
maintenance for about three months now
my whole quarantine has been maintenance
until
june 1st i started my cut i
i felt physically incredible like
i was it's been so awful not to be able
to go to a gym
yeah because i'm really strong and have
all this energy
and like it's a little bittersweet that
i'm starting this cut
and gyms will open eventually soon and
i'll be on a cut yeah you know i was
strong two months ago i swear
yeah yeah in my basement you know
lifting my kettlebell i was an animal
yeah honestly i promise
um so i wanted to bring up something
that i think is quite timely
which is the difference in the public
response
to your transformation and the public's
response to
adele's transformation what are your
thoughts on that
um i want to
back up for one minute to say
that i i i it is stark from what i've
looked at in the news and even comments
i've gotten
on social media and even conversations
i've had in life
um and it's kind of heartbreaking
that i've gotten only seemingly only
accolades you know
every for every 200 comments on social
media there's a guy going you're still
fat and i'm like okay i can't win with
you you're a dick
yeah nothing i will ever do will be
good for you so i'm you're not my guy um
and to hear anybody say anything look i
look at pictures of adele
at any point and i think she's a pretty
girl
an attractive girl but i see the most
recent i think there's only one picture
i've seen of her recently
where she's like she is ecstatic and she
is
glowing and she is doing a look at me
picture right and i'm like she's not
nearly as happy in these other pictures
she's winning awards and she's [ __ ]
hot she's dope singer like all this and
she looks clearly happy
but she is not as stoked in those
earlier pictures so i'm
how can you be anything but like stoked
for this girl and go like
i want to pat her on the back and say
you did great
the fact that anybody can tie any kind
of
um psychological [ __ ] that only
exists within themselves
onto her and say that she's
harming people or whatever i think is
ridiculous you know
she's a girl who had a goal who made her
goal or
got as close to it as she possibly could
i have had that in 2012 or 11
when i was obsessively bicycling and i
got what i felt like was too
thin there were stories that
paparazzi would follow me around riding
my bike and take pictures of the loose
skin on my legs and
write like the downside of weight loss
and
look at how terrible he looks like i had
i experienced that
um so i i don't know
what it is uh i
certainly wasn't as confident in myself
then
so i kind of would see these stories and
go yeah they're right i
i don't look great i'm uh
they're right i couldn't argue with them
and
this time i was releasing pictures of
myself
going like i [ __ ] [ __ ] you if you
think i don't look good i know i like
first off if anyone has the balls to
come up to someone who now looks like
you
and say that they're a very brave person
you know yeah
i will crush you if you're looking i've
got 250 cows
right i've got 150 cal on my left hand
another one in my right and i've got a
belt
fed machine gun chain of bullets around
my
don't [ __ ] with me yeah yeah i i don't
i i think girls have it
harder than guys do as far as
the aesthetics go you know which is uh
maybe that's publicly because i know
like guys with each other like me and my
friends are constantly picking each
other apart you know and
talking about bizarre things that really
shouldn't matter but they do matter to
us and
you know how how does your bicep vein
rest at the exact
center of your bicep or is it cocked
over to one side and
how do we fix that you know we all know
we all know each other's pain points as
well right like you know
the thing you can say to your buddy like
everyone's got that one
lad friend who's going a little bit thin
a little bit early in life
yeah you know you can always be like
dude just put something on your head
like the shine off the top of it's
killing me or you've got like
the guy that's a bit short or the guy
that's a bit whatever you know they do
that and
i wonder i don't know man i i was
fascinated watching
the adele situation unfold and
the layers upon layers of people saying
congratulations adele
you've done really well this is great
you're a role model for people to
lose weight then there was the reaction
that was
um big girls don't think that just
because adele's lost weight to conform
to society's beauty ideals that you need
to lose weight as well you're beautiful
too
then there was the like third layer of
people
that were saying how dare these people
say that she shouldn't have lost weight
this is and i'm like this is like
dante's inferno
we're just descending through all the
layers of hell here
like there are certain things that are
unarguable facts
obesity is an all-cause mortality risk
fact number one yeah you die sooner
of everything if you're fat so
anybody that says you
singer in the public limelight should
sacrifice your health
literally sacrifice your life your
mortality your risk of
everything to be a role model
for other people to also shorten their
lives
that that sort of blew my mind but on
the flip side of that
i when especially when i contrasted that
with your
journey i'm like wow there is something
going on here
between is it because of who you are is
it because of the industry you're in
i don't think so is it because of your
gender i think it is
i think i think the vast majority of it
is
that guys have a bigger overton window
like a larger leeway of guys can kind of
get
real thin guys can get real fat and it's
kind of just like we just still a bloke
you know there is there is no beauty
standard
for men there's like a hotness standard
but you're supposed to have like
a long hair coming out your nose that
you haven't seen once in a while which
gentleman under the age of 30. these
random things are going to begin
happening to you where you're just going
to find like an elephant hair in the
middle of your forehead and
time's a cruel mistress um like all this
stuff's going to happen
but you're right like there's this
there's still sort of this beauty
standard for women even as you get all
that dame judy dench you know being
graceful
as she gets towards later age and stuff
like that
and i don't know what it is man i don't
know what i do know is that i was real
disheartened by women's
response to adele yeah me too
and men but it's some men too who are
male feminists who are like
but yeah man it's just looking to please
some group by saying they were playing
the pl
please the women game yeah but like
girls and guys were supportive of you
yeah the vast majority of guys that i
saw commenting online
were either commenting on women slating
adele or complimenting adele
yeah but then the girls side of stuff i
wasn't seeing much vitriol from men
i was seeing a lot of vitriol from girls
and it's like hang on a second
are we not supposed to be backing our
own team here
like you need to gas up the people who
you want to do well in life like
adele is an amazing role model for girls
yes maybe that makes someone who is
overweight
uncomfortable at the fact that adele was
showing me that you can be both
successful
and overweight but now you have someone
who is showing you that if you are
overweight
you can be in a healthy range not
because of
society's beauty standards forget that
like i'm not playing that game
i'm playing the game of you will live
longer
and by the judgment of her photo and as
you
identified yourself this glow that she
had
potentially be happier yeah
i think that i think there's there can
be a lot of things that are true at the
same time
which for me
uh there does become a level of
subjectivity to health
so yes if we are
urging towards long-term survival
not being overweight benefits that sure
but at the same time i go like what
business is of
mine how people choose to live
you know so i'm like you want to drink
you want to do drugs
you want to drive your car too fast you
want to do reckless things
you want to get coronavirus i don't
really care
don't [ __ ] mess with me and
don't do unsafe things to me
and we're good uh and i know there is
some argument that talks about the
burden
on health care with obesity that it
suddenly does
become an affect larger numbers of
people
and i go like that's too abstract for me
if we're talking about individuals
how an individual chooses to live
doesn't really matter to me and i won't
criticize them
i've noticed um quite a bit
recently of young girls
who when i was a kid uh you would never
see an overweight young girl in kind of
a midriff shirt
showing her belly you wouldn't see that
and i see it today
and the the girls seem to have i choose
girls because
this is i have four daughters and i'm
just more aware of
their friends and like what girls are
doing than i am with young
guys there is a higher sense of
confidence
certainly or less of a shame around
being overweight which i think is a good
thing because i don't think i
i think that it's for me there was
something about
um being introverted
and uh most of my
eating was which i do consider to be
harming myself self-harm
was being done privately because i was
ashamed of it
and i didn't ever have the confidence in
myself
to try and change that until i met a
girl
who didn't seem to care about it at all
and then i went like
[ __ ] i'm worthwhile you know i'm gonna
do something about this and it was kind
of this kind of magical
uh confluence of events that led me to
be able to do that so
i wouldn't posit my ideas on adele but i
you see it quite a bit in people who
become
successful and then lose weight and it's
a you know it could be part of that like
confidence boost when i
i have uh
tens of thousands of private messages on
instagram which i will never get through
all of them it's just not possible
and every now and again i'll open it and
i'll pick one at random and
more commonly than not it's somebody
saying
you made me less ashamed as a fat person
uh because you seemed to be very
successful
and were a very confident fat person
which is not necessarily true i was not
a super confident fat person
and now that you've lost the weight
you've inspired me
to also do that that's like a double
whammy
yeah [ __ ] don't i feel good about
myself you know
that's so amazing it's amazing because i
don't think
people should be going around ashamed
about their bodies i think that's
not necessarily good and what my ideas
are about health for myself
and even if i think about what i think
is right
for health for other people i don't want
to put that on them
and say that anybody should or should
not lose weight
however i think more often than not
people have the idea of wanting to do
something
and then feeling incapable of doing it
and so to say like you can do it
it's totally possible it's some hard
work and
here are these points of inspiration
which you could draw from
i think is only a good thing so i i get
very
torn in in many directions with
like of course adele should be
patted on the back she's [ __ ] did
something she wanted to do
she didn't do that because somebody said
she was going to sell more records
or because her boyfriend doesn't sell
more records than adele
she's already sold all the records yeah
there you go she's
she got to a point in her life where sh
what
for whatever reason then who knows what
they are she decided to do this
and she did it and she's happy about it
and we should only applaud her
we shouldn't build our
psychosis into her motives or anything
else i think it's not fair
um and i don't know if the men
are more give her more affinity for this
goal
because men are genuine generally
or statistically more attracted to thin
women i have no idea what it is but i
see the same thing as you it's very
very disappointing just layers to it
which you said and
it's not just this isn't just like three
or four things being true at once this
is like 10 things
10 different things being true at once
and as we know
people struggle with complexity it's
significantly easier especially on
twitter you know twitter doesn't have
the room
uh it actually does not have the spatial
capacity for new ones you have 360
characters something like that
you can put across like a dally's fat
adele is thin adele shouldn't have got
thin adele should have got like you know
you you can only do a small number of
these
of these stories that you put across but
man like
i think if you have got messages like
that that said not only have you given
me confidence to be successful at the
weight i'm at
but then also to make that transition
into being someone
who is a more uh normal bmi
wow like that for me is the highest
compliment i could have
gotten because i don't think
people are going to be super successful
at achieving
a goal a physical goal out of shame i
just don't think that's true
um shame could be early impetus or
whatever
i don't know exactly but i don't think
long-term success will come out of shame
i think you need to have
confidence in yourself and your
abilities and
work more from that position i don't
know that
um a lot of these girls who are body
positive
have never thought i'd be happier look
for me
at the end of the day i just want to fit
in an airline seat
i just want to not have to ask for an
extension
you know and and there's no part of me
that thinks they need to make airline
seats bigger
i think those are built for averages now
as society gets bigger
maybe they will eventually but like even
today
the averages say that that's the seat so
you don't need to make a bigger seat i
would rather just have a body that fits
in the average seat that's all
yeah i think there's there's two um
approaches when you see that happen
there's one
one person who says good for you and
and i want to use that and another
person who says oh my god
this identifies my shortcoming as long
as
adele or ethan remain overweight
that justifies my being overweight if
they're able to do it
oh ball's in my court now
yeah you know like one less fat person
is one less person
on team fat yeah and one more person on
team
i think unfortunately that
we move uh we seemingly move into the
realm
where um
the group kind of sets the truth
and there is less and less individual
truth
and so like if i like uh
if i like strawberry ice cream and i
think it's the greatest ice cream
nothing you say about strawberry ice
cream
can alter my feeling about strawberry
ice cream
so i don't see why anything you say
about my feelings about myself
should be able to alter my feelings
about myself but
we've gotten into this space where
the group can dictate how
people view themselves and not only that
the group must dictate how people view
themselves and i go like you've lost me
i can't play that game i can only know
what's true for me
i cannot say what's true for you i will
not say what's true for you
but i know what's true for me and uh
you can offer a bunch of evidence that
may alter my view
of what's true for me that's possible
and i welcome you to do that because i'm
always looking for new
[ __ ] if i had just stuck with keto i
wouldn't
have the muscle definition that i have
now i just wouldn't um
and i'm so happy that i i'm
really pleased with my body right now
that could be
sound like the most [ __ ]
materialistic
vain thing to say but i work my ass off
and
have been for 20 years on having a body
i'm happy
with and i'm like just finally going
check me out you know what i mean like
it takes the right lighting but with the
right lighting i've got a six-pack
that's
[ __ ] wild dude you're gonna have
come gutters ab veins
i can't wait like that is exciting you
know what i mean
um and that's just for me and my wife i
guess
yeah i mean what an investment what an
investment by her as well you know
one little one little suggestion of a
diet
and then before you know it so a decade
goes by
and then you've got like the 21st
century bearded incarnation of rambo
yeah next to you know like [ __ ] this
this is that's easy man what a glow up
what
and she and her to her credit too
i was kind of going along just like a
couple years ago after
i had been going to the gym and gaining
weight and all this and then
for the second series of the show chance
i decided to lose weight and i was just
really hiking
and at one point she was like you're
spending a lot of time
out there hiking in the hills behind our
house um
why don't you work on abs she says to me
and i'm like oh
i'm okay that's interesting okay i'll do
that and it became this
intense focus you know um
but she definitely bounces me around and
it was
literally just her going i bet you could
go to the gym for an hour
rather than spending five hours hiking
around in the hills and she was right
ultimately
dude wives unfortunately they just tend
to be don't i mean i wouldn't i wouldn't
know i'm
hopelessly hopelessly single which isn't
being helped by either this mustache or
by lockdown but um
it is what it is dude man this been
awesome uh
yeah i feel like we could have gone on
for forever so you got your podcast
american gluten
american glutton which is so much fun um
yeah and as soon as we're allowed to
work we'll see what that is like
belthead machine guns
dude i'm so ready for that you know yeah
so ready for it look
um links to ethan socials his
fantastic podcast american glut which
you should absolutely go and check out
will be linked in the show notes below
if you enjoyed this episode feel free to
give me a message you know where to find
me at chriswell x on all social media
man thanks ethan it's been sick thank
you it was a pleasure
let's do it again sometime i'm in all
right
[Music]